we're asked to apply the distributive
property and we have one half times the
expression two a minus six b plus eight
so to figure this out i've i've actually
already copy and pasted this problem
onto my scratch pad i have it right over
here one half times two a minus six b
plus eight so let me just rewrite it so
i'm going to take and only color code it
too just for fun so it's going to be one
half
times
give myself some space
one half times
2 a
minus 6b
so
2a
minus 6b
minus
6. let me write it this way
minus
6b and then we have plus eight
plus and i will do eight in
this color
plus eight and so i just need to
distribute the one-half if i'm
multiplying one-half times this entire
expression that means i multiply
one-half times each of these terms so
i'm going to multiply one-half times
this
one-half times this and one-half times
that
so one-half times 2a so it's going to be
one-half
times 2a
times
let me do that same color so you see
where the 2a came from
one-half times 2a
minus
minus one-half times 6b
minus one-half
times six b
times six b
plus
plus one half times eight
one half
times
times eight and so what's this going to
be
well let's see i have
one half times two a one half times two
is just one so you're just going to be
left with a
and then you have minus
one half times six b well we could just
think about what one-half times 6 is
going to be one-half times 6 is going to
be 3 and then you still are multiplying
times b so it's going to be 3 b
and then we have
plus
1 half times 8 half of 8 is 4 or as you
say eight halves is equal to four wholes
all right so this is going to be four
so it's a minus three b
plus four
a minus three b plus four so let's type
that in it's going to be a
minus 3b
plus
4. and notice i just it's literally half
of each of these terms half of 2a is a
half of 6b is 3b so we have minus 6b so
it's going to be -3b and plus 8 instead
of that half of that plus 4. so let's
check our answer
and we got it right let's do
let's do another one of these
so let's say
so they say apply the distributive
property to factor out the greatest
common factor and here we have 60 m
minus 40. so let me get my scratch pad
out again
so
i'm running out of space that way
so
we have
alright like this
we have 60
60 m
minus 40
minus
40.
so what is the greatest common factor of
60 m and 40. well 10 might jump out at
us we might say okay look you know 60 is
10 so we could say this is the same
thing as 10
times 6 and actually and then of course
you have the m there so you could use 10
times 6m and then you could view
you could view this as
10
times 4.
but we 10 still isn't the greatest
common factor and you say well sal how
do you know that well because 4
and 6 still share a factor in common
they still share two
so what if you're actually factoring out
the greatest common factor what's left
should not share a factor with each
other so let me let me think even harder
about what a greatest common factor of
60 and 40 is
well
2 times 10 is 20.
so you could actually factor out a 20.
so you have 20 and
30 m sorry 20 and 3m and 40 can be
factored out into 20
and
20 and 2. and now 3m and 2
3m and 2 share no common factor so you
know that you have fully factored these
two things out now if you think that
this is something kind of a strange art
that i just did one way to think about
greatest common factors you say okay 60.
you can literally do a prime
factorization you say 60 is 2 times
30 which is 2 times 15
which is three times five so that's 60's
prime factorization 2 times 2 times 3
times 5 and then 40's prime
factorization
is 2 times 20 20 is 2 times 10
10 is 2 times
5. so that right over here this is 40's
prime factorization and to get out the
greatest common factor you want to get
out as many common prime factors so you
have here you have two twos and a five
here you have two twos and a five you
can't go to three twos into five because
there aren't three twos and a five over
here so you have two twos and a five
here
two twos and a five here so two times
two times five is going to be the
greatest common factor
so 2 times 2 times 5 that's 4 times 5 4
times 5 that is 20. that's one way of
kind of very systematically figuring out
a greatest common factor but anyway now
that we know that 20 is the greatest
common factor let's factor it out so
this is going to be equal to 20
times
so 60 divided 60 m divided by 20 you're
just going to be left with 3m
just going to be left with 3m and then
minus minus 40 divided by 20 you're just
left with the 2
minus 2
minus 2. so let's type that in
so this is going to be
20
times
20 times 3m
3m
minus 2. and once again we feel good
that we literally we did take out the
the greatest common factor because 3m
and 2 especially 3 and 2 are now
relatively prime relatively prime just
means they don't share any factors in
common other than 1.